こんにちははじめしゃちょーです今日です
ねちょっと有明の方に来てるんですけれど
もなんと今日ですねここ東京ガーデン
シアターでですねなんとYouTube
クリエイターが集まって
uffesっていう大人気のイベントが
よろしいんですよ
すごい今日ねきっとすごい人が来るのよ
ちょっと見てみる大人気クリエイター
初めて社長は今回出ないはじめしゃちょー
俺も好きなんだけど
忙しくて来ないらしくて見てくださいなん
とUUMが10周年ということで記念す
べきフェスもう超でかいufeにはじめ
社長は来ない
忙しいらしいんですよマジで忙しそう
ウェルカムほらピンクの可愛いの
すごい見てくれほらすごい
歴史とか
ガチャガチャガチャとかこれとかも見て
ください
ウームの歴史を感じますね
プレゼント入れる場所いろんな
クリエイター
わかるね
一応あるぞ
出ないのに
なんでだろうなちょっと前出しとこう
ちょっと食い気味にしときたい
いやもう
げん玉こういう感じですねユーフェスこん
だけたくさんYouTuber
HIKAKINさんとかフィッシャーズと
かもうみんな来るとお客さん絶対たくさん
来るんですよ今日ヒット今日絶対すごい
ことになるので今日近くでたこ焼き屋さん
やったら売れるんじゃないかということで
今日たこ焼き屋さんをやってみたいと思い
ますたこ焼き屋さんなんですねはい
ちょっと俺はね尖りたいのよ今日は夕飯の
隣ではじめ社長がたこ焼き屋さんやって
たらどうなるのかちょっとやってみたいと
思います
[音楽]
はいというわけで今日はここでたこ焼き屋
さんやっていきたいと思いますもうあの
多分いろんなYouTuberのファンが
来るからかなりスタッフたくさん
準備させていただきました
永遠にたこ焼き作れるもう設備ができてる
のでこれでもう今日はたくさんたこ焼き
売っていきたいと思いますここでたこ焼き
を作って
梱包してお店あそこで出すっていう感じ
これ衝撃的なこと言っていいたこ焼き作っ
たことないんですよなんでたこ焼き大学の
時タコバとかしたんだけど
団地で作らせてたんよなるほど食べるに
徹するみたいな
例えばたこ焼きみたいなとこあるから
ちょっと今日たこ焼きで行かせました
じゃあちょっと作ってみたいと思います
よろしくお願いしますすいません実はです
ね一度も作ったことがなくて大丈夫ですご
安心ください先生よろしくお願いします
なるほどなるほど
同じようにこの2面ですねはい行きます
うまいですか
これで全体になじませるということですね
45度に入れてこう
やってきましたここから灼熱になります
シャックネッツ
火つけていきます
ここから生地を引いてきます
お願いしますさあいよいよ生地を引いて
いきます
大体同じぐらいの厚さで引いてあげて
くださいはい行きます
奥の方から
もう一箇所にバーって流す感じ1か所であ
これたこ焼き作るの楽しいなじゃ次行き
ますはい
すごい入れますね
結構あのあれですね手が
研げました感じました感じましたたこ焼き
屋さん暑いんだたこ焼き2個入っちゃい
ました1個にしてくださいわかりました
このぐらいの量で全体に
やばいめっちゃくちゃ俺下手だ
大丈夫です
それ違いますね
[音楽]
いやすごい
これ同じように真ん中を使ってやってき
ましたはいわかりましたまずは周りを
切ります
でこうしてこう来てはいこうです
どっかやってましたはい
その調子で左の面も行っちゃいますはい
はいじゃあ次2回目の開始をいきますはい
今1回目でこう上がってるじゃないですか
えっとね中でマスクしてるこれすごいね
汗すごいやばい
よ
暑いね
髪色も相まってたこ焼き屋さんぽいね
ちょっともうちょっと習ってくるわ飛び出
てるところを形が変なところ白いところを
わかりました
転がったらもうどんどん下に行って
ください
めっちゃ綺麗
[音楽]
俺がやったことになってます
よしちょっと一通り終わりました
[音楽]
合格ですありがとうございます
じゃあこの辺の綺麗なのお客様に食べて
いただいてくださいはいできました
素晴らしいですありがとうございます
売りもするのであんまり来れないかもしれ
ないんですけども時間があればちょっと
たこ焼きも作っていきたいと思います
ありがとうございました今日はよろしくお
願いします
暑いねじゃあ今日ありがとうございました
これから
ちょっと見に行こうかもうすぐオープン
ですねあと10分後ぐらいです
はい待ってめっちゃ並んでるんだけども
あーこれは
儲かるわすごいね皆さんもうしばしお待ち
ください
たこ焼き最高
ありがとう
[音楽]
たこ焼き屋さんオープンします
ありがとうございますお味いかがされます
か
[音楽]
入ります上がソースで下がポン酢になって
おりますありがとうございますありがとう
ございますありがとうございましたまたの
ご来店お待ちしておりますいらっしゃい
ません
ありがとうございます1日頑張って
くださいありがとうございますありがとう
ございますご来店お待ちしております
はいというわけでたくさん並んでるんです
けれどもちょっともっと
ブーストをかけるためにTwitterに
もあげちゃいます
この時代話そうかこんにちは
本当に3億円のお家はね
買っちゃったよ買っちゃったんだ実はまた
ね
いらっしゃいませこんにちは
2つください
[音楽]
2つあります
ありがとうございます
すご
いらっしゃいませんあれ
トミーがいるぞ
いいよ
すいません買いに来ました普通にトミー
さんいらっしゃいません
お待ちしております
ありがとうございます
ありがとうございますすいませんお邪魔し
ました
ありがとうございました
はいというわけで11時になったので1
時間経過しました
身長が高いのでまっすぐ立つとこうなっ
ちゃうんです
常に中腰でやってるので結構腰がやばい
ですね声は自信があるのでまだ出て行き
ます何時まででしたっけ9時
あと10時間頑張りたいと思います
はいというわけで結構
バーって売れちゃっててなんと今たこ焼き
屋さん100円不足に陥ってしまいました
お釣りがないんだってもうこれかなり
ちょっとやばいので1個800円で1個
買えば1600円2,100円出して
くれれば500円玉で返せるから呼びかけ
しすぎます100円不足なんです
理想だけ出してください2個買うと
1600円2100円出して500円玉の
お釣りが最高ですただ無理にとは言いませ
ん
お金ちょうだい実際にさ味を伝えるのが
一番大事だと思うんだよいただきます
[音楽]
緊急事態です売れすぎて
商品が間に合ってないという事態が起きて
おります
職人より早く売れてるから売りすぎて今
明太マヨしかないらしいんですよ
欲しい人だけ募集してみるか
すいませんたこ焼きが間に合ってなくて
明太マヨだけあるみたいなんですけど
明大前は欲しいって言っときます
一番好きのお客様どうぞ
明太マヨ以外も復活してきたみたいです
[音楽]
妹は最近よ
やめろやめろお疲れ様です12時です12
時かオープン2時間部屋のねノンストップ
ラビッツだね
ノンラビだよすごいやっぱ色んな人が来て
くれて
止まってない永遠にもうたこ焼き出し続け
てるっていうとてもありがたいです
よ
そんなことないですけどちょっとまだ12
時でしょもうちょい頑張りましょうか
[音楽]
えーとですね
100円が不足しています結構
準備してもらってたはずなんだけどねどう
する一旦
閉店するかそうするか今いるお客さんだけ
とりあえず100円たくさん欲しいという
ことだけ伝えてくるわ皆さんすいません
100円玉がないでーすあげます
ありがとうございますあと明太子も実は
ちょっとあの人気がないと言いますか明太
子食べてみたいなっていう方いらっしゃい
ましたら是非ともご注文いただきますと
幸いでございます100円玉のちょっと
少ないのでもしお財布に100円玉ある方
いらっしゃいましたらちょっと出して
いただけるととてもありがたいです
よろしくお願いしますはいというわけで
ちょっとたこ焼きも足りない状況100円
玉も不足しているということで今並んで
くださる方で1回止めて当然伸ばしてやる
ようですいろいろ準備が整ったらここの部
再開したいと思います
[音楽]
ここのたこ焼き屋さん
美味しいんだって知ってるここ
いるの
がベッドやってんのーでそれがここにある
んだけどちょっと食べてみようかな
いただきます
これ絶対みんな食べた方がいいかもしれ
ない
[音楽]
[拍手]
入ります
[音楽]
やばいやばい
ありがとうございます
多分ねもう入ってる人ほとんど買ってると
思うんですよね割とね
美味しかったなぁうまかったなぁ
こんなところにモチベーション
[音楽]
[拍手]
ちょっと気をつけてくださいありがとう
ございます
どうも夜です今7時ぐらいなんですけども
だいぶ暗くなってきました雨が降りそうな
んですよちょっと天気が悪くなってきたの
で雨降るとさすがにちょっとスーツになる
可能性があるのでドキドキしてますなんと
か逃げ切りたい頑張ります再開します
[音楽]
入りました
全
[音楽]
種類2個です8個入りました
ありがとうございます入り
ます
はいというわけでまもなく20時になり
ます残り1時間ぐらいですでここからユー
フェスが終わるのでまたちょっと優位性を
見に来てくださっていたお客さんが帰って
くるのでそこでまた人が来るかなと思って
ます今のところタイムなく永遠にお客さん
が来てるのでノンストップで本当にあとは
1時間ぐらいですかねちょっと
頑張りたいと思います
[拍手]
[音楽]
はい終了30分前で雨が降ってきました雨
降ってるんですけども列がすごいことに
なってるのでなんとかこのまま走りきり
たいと思います最後まで頑張ります
こんにちはどうぞいらっしゃいませ
こんにちはどうぞありがとう
いかがいたしましょう
メンマ予想ソースでポン酢でごめんね
ありがとうございます
お待たせしましたありがとうございます
[音楽]
ありがとうございます最後までお疲れ様
でしたありがとうございましたじゃあ3
種類
ぐらい
しました見えから来たのありがとうござい
ます
バイバイ
ありがとうございました
[音楽]
皆さんありがとうございましたありがとう
ございますありがとうございました
失礼します
ありがとうございましたありがとうござい
ました
ありがとうございます
ありがとうございましたお疲れ様です
MVPよ
1日中これしてたらさすがにきついよ
じゃあちょっと1回動画飛びますたこ焼き
屋さん1日やってみてから1日経ちました
お疲れ様ですありがとうございました
来てくださった皆様本当にありがとう
ございましたちょっと
至らぬ点もあったり展望が悪かったりで
かなり待たせてしまったりとかこう
もたついてしまった部分はあったんです
けれどもすごくたくさんのお客様が来て
くださいました
並びすぎててあんまりちゃんと対応ができ
なくてほんと申し訳なかったんですけれど
もYouTuberのイベント最高やな
うん最高やった
びっくりするぐらい人が来ておりました
視聴者さんとか色んな方にはじめはUS出
ないのとか言われてますけれどもあれは僕
なりの出方です初めてのufsからはじめ
しゃちょー毎回出させていただいててもう
ほんと感謝と
楽しいんですけども
いつまでも同じことしたくねえなと
ちょっと尖りたいなというか
違ったことをUSの中でできたらいいかな
と思って俺はねあれぐらいの距離感が好き
だなっていう感じはしましたもちろんなん
かイベントに上がるのもすごい面白いし
楽しいですけども俺できることねえし俺
できることねえしあの
けん玉ちょっとできるぐらいあとポケカ
あとステージに上がって何かするよりかは
俺はねはじめしゃちょ人間はあれくらいの
距離でたこ焼き売ってるのが僕なんか
すごい俺には合ってたなと思ったし
楽しかったししてくださった皆様もなんか
すごい楽しそうだったらねもう何よりでし
たというわけで気になる売上結果ですね
すごかったですよ別に見ました日中も私夜
も結構やばい時はもう階段の下までいっ
ちゃいますみたいなものすごい列ができて
たのでかなり売り上げがありそうに見えて
たこ焼き渡せの最初の頃は2人でやってた
んです僕とスタッフの人といやこれ私の俺
の方がいいなってことになって途中から
ワンオペになってたんでほぼ1人で渡して
たんで回転率はそんなに高くはないかなと
いう感じではありますで聞いた話なんです
けどもあれたこ焼き屋さんとかあの1日の
売り上げの平均でだいたい30万ぐらい
らしいです
では発表いたします
今回
YouTuberのイベントの隣で1日
たこ焼き屋さんをやった結果
販売個数
2,732個
売上金額
218万5600円
たこ焼きほぼ一人でお渡ししてたっていう
その回転率の悪さとかたこ焼き作るとか
間に合わなくて結構お待たせしてしまった
のも含めるとすごい方なのじゃない
でしょうかいろんな要素があるんだろうな
YouTuberのイベントの隣でやって
たのもあるし店員がはじめしゃ社長だった
のもちょっとあると思います悪い点もあり
ました天気がちょっと悪かった風が強いと
か列が長すぎるとかいろんな悪いっても
あったと思いますけども
諸々含めて
218万5600円でございました動画に
使います
[音楽]